herzlich willkommen hier aus unseren
trainingsbereich heute haben wir für
euch ein programm ein sensomotorik und
gleichgewichtstraining das hatten wir
bereits in der ersten woche einmal
wichtig sturzprophylaxe ausgleichen
tiefenmuskulatur entsprechend trainieren
und vorbereiten gelenke stabilisieren
das ist der inhalt was man heute
versuchen mit euch gemeinsam zu
trainieren
gestern waren auch intensives workout
mit dem rucksack und der cattle bell und
morgen als kleiner ausblick wir haben
ein training mit einem stab gymnastik
starb besen stimmt was auch immer ihr
zur hand hat es mit euch machen
da wird dass der fokus wieder auf der
rückenmuskulatur liegen das heißt heute
sensomotorik morgan rücken
wir haben deinen spezialgast heute bei
uns das ist johannes panik ein zugführer
als leistungssportler europacupsieger im
fechten ich der peter bin wieder da und
der manuel ist auch mit dabei
aber am besten ist du stellst dich ganz
kurz vor bitte ja hallo mein name ist
johannes ich bin vechta ich bin herr
sportler und ich freue mich dass ich mit
euch heute das training gemeinsam machen
kann sagt frage noch zu beginn das
sensomotorik training das
gleichgewichtstraining wie wichtig ist
es für ein fechter das ist für ein
fechter genauso wichtig wie für jeden
anderen menschen auch für uns vielleicht
sogar noch wichtiger
ok gebracht es tagtäglich natürlich im
sport das sind dynamische bewegungen
ausfallschritte wenn man sieht dass ein
bisschen ins geistige auge geholt wie
gefecht bewegung ausschaut und das muss
man natürlich muskulär stabilisieren
können und dafür ist diese art des
trainings natürlich optimal okay du bist
bereit
du bist du bereit aufwärmen braucht man
für diese art von training jetzt nicht
so wie für ein militär in
fitnesstraining beispielsweise wo man
schon beim aufwärmen das erste mal so
richtig zum schlafen und zum schwitzen
kommt das ist nicht ganz so tragisch
aber trotzdem wir haben gelernt von
diversen sportlern auch das durch
mobilisieren der gelenke täglich das
schaut gar nix und damit vor allem
frauen in deutschland beginnen mal unten
sprunggelenk das heißt bei 1 10 abtippen
und dann in eine richtung drehen erkennt
sie nach außen und nach innen drehen
einmal das ist auch eine variante die
anscheinend doch möglich ist die
richtung wechseln wo siehst du dein
sportliches ziel was ist das highlight
was planst als nächstes
in tokio okay das heißt qualifikation
steht noch aus oder qualifikation steht
noch aus die frage seit wann vor den
problemen stimme alle deswegen feet aus
dem lockt dann betrifft nicht nur die
leistungssportler sondern eben auch euch
zu hause
die trainieren weiter wir trainieren
weiter so schaffen wir das gemeinsam
erst einmal die seite und weiß gott mir
auffällt der johannes hat turnschuhe an
mangelt nicht was ist der große
unterschied genau dann kann man sich
wirklich auf das konzentrieren auf das
ausgleichen natürlich beim fechten habe
die schuhe an
deshalb trainiert seit ich sensomotorik
mit den schuhen damit man dort das bild
an etwa fälschen
ok dann gehen wir ein gelenk weiter aufs
kniegelenk gut hilft reiter stand hände
aufs knie kreisky richtung wechseln weil
das linke bein hoch glaubt man mal das
bein auf und so das heißt nach vor und
zurück das sei erst einmal immerhin
stand das alles erst einmal im
gleichgewicht halten in einer
dynamischen bewegung dann muss das stand
schon arbeiten seite wechseln und wieder
abstellen hüftgelenk leer rechtes bein
beginnen hochziehen nach außen drehen da
kann man gleich fünf mal nach hinten
drehen versuchen möglichst große kreise
zu drehen danach selbstständig auf die
rechte seite wechseln
johannes du sagst du trainierst viele
stunden nämlich einmal pro woche
ja genau was genau haben wir das
zusammen
da ist wahlweise irgendwas zwischen 20
und 25 stunden pro woche ok also auch
hochintensive belastungen die da dabei
sind und wie gesagt auch das
sensomotorik training ist täglich die
familie programm
ok dann wieder ausloggen greifen wir mal
den oberkörper bewegen wir treten bei
den oberkörper von links nach rechts und
kleinen wechsels arme kreisen vorwärts
große kreise beginnt rückwärts eine hand
vor einer zurück
also gegen gleich richtung wechseln und
dem auslagern ausschütteln bus seitlich
hoch geben im unterarm kreisen und die
richtung wechseln
herne zusammen im handgelenk kreisen
und auch ob alle selbständig einfach die
richtung wechseln
genau und wir sind heiß über seile
bereits angekommen blick wendung linke
seite rechte seite einfach selbständiger
beim hin- und herwechseln
und der wechsel nach oben und nach unten
und nach links und nach rechts gibt dann
haben wir kurze rotation mit hinein
halbkreise kinn vor der brust hin und
her bewegen und damit kurz aus lockern
am besten ist zu hause ihr richtet sich
jetzt eure gymnastikmatte her rollt sie
zusammen fixiert das ganze vielleicht
mit dem klebeband das ganze braucht man
dann für unser workout während jedes
macht ganz kurz eine frage auch an dich
du trainierst sehr viel kann man von dem
sport in österreich leben
wir haben das glück dass wir ein
bundesheer angestellt sind also
ermöglicht uns das weil es gibt bei uns
keine keine preisgelder in anderen
sportarten und die möglichkeit dass wir
das professionell machen können gibt uns
bisher also ihr könnt jetzt quasi den
sport gar nicht ausüben waren wir diese
möglichkeit nicht hätte jetzt ja nicht
so professionell lösen können auch keine
tiefe
danke für diese fehleinschätzung also
das ist ja ganz wichtiger punkt auch die
leistungssportler im bundesheer die
unterstützt werden wie gesagt ansonsten
gäbe ist diesen sport auf diesem hohen
niveau in österreich gar nicht okay dann
würde ich sagen
fangen wir einfach einmal an die erste
übung mit wolfsburg in bananen und
[Applaus]
versucht einfach einmal im wege stand
auf einmal bis eine tomate vertraut zu
machen
nach vorgibt ein bisschen zurückblicken
zuschauen wie reagiert dieses ding unter
meinen beinen was ich normalerweise
nicht ab dass man es danach gut eben
entsprechend ausgleichen kann
denn auf der innenkante rollen auf der
außenkante rollen die
unterschiedlichsten varianten einfach da
mal ausprobieren
wichtig beim sensomotorik training beim
gleichgewichtstraining den muskel nicht
zu überlasten die gelenke muskulatur
ermüdet sehr rasch das heißt die braucht
er dann natürlich immer wieder pause das
heißt am besten steigt wieder herunter
titelt die beine aus das was wir jetzt
machen die kniebeuge kennt sie und wir
versuchen jetzt einmal eine kniebeuge
eine ganz kleine bewegungen beginnen
also keine tief gebäude am anfang
sondern eine viertel kniebeuge und
schauen wir mal ob das automatik ganz
gut funktioniert wir probiert das
auskennt solcher die hände fürs
gleichgewicht mitnehmen oder nach oben
strecken weil es als besonders
schwieriger haben wird es ab bord
zentimeter nach unten zentimeter nach
oben 10 15 reichen aber voll und ganz
aus achtet auf eure beinachse das ist
ganz wichtig beim ausgleichen
das kniegelenk wir zum ausgleich nicht
verwendet das bleibt stabil
ok und wieder runter von der matte kurz
auslagern ausschüttung genau so schaut
es aus wir geben da muskulatur die
möglichkeit sich entsprechend zu erholen
ja das ist ein ganz wichtiger punkt da
nicht überlasten das ist kein hartes
intensives körperliches werk hat heute
so nämlich gesagt zum gleichgewicht für
die sensomotorik ganz wichtig ok dann
braucht ihr maßnahme zweite option
kniebeuge etwas tiefer
ja es ist ja da muss man schon aus dem
sprunggelenk aus den beinen heraus
auch aus dem fuß natürlich ganz viel
mehr stabilisieren dass wirtschaft wird
spannend für den einen oder anderen zwei
wiederholungen macht man bauen wieder
runterkommen aus lockern
johannes im europacup sieg kopenhagen
hast du mir vorher erzählt
es gibt dazu zu sagen wieviel kämpfe
hautnah wie lange dauert so was war das
damals einen ganzen tag dieser wettkampf
er wie viele wettkämpfe haben wir da bis
zum finale 12 bis 13 wettkämpfen man
muss natürlich schon ab einem gewissen
zeitpunkt jedem zu jedes jeden kampf zu
gewinnen weil wir der gewinner geht
weiter das ist weder ko system
wahlsystem hat sich im judo
hoffnungsrunde dabei also draußen immer
drei mal draußen immer draußen das heißt
du hast dann zehn zwölf kämpfe einen tag
genau und da muss man gewinnen kann man
sie doch immer wieder darauf vorbereiten
doch wie geht s ja also man hat ein
bisserl so zeitraum zwischen den
wettkämpfen zwischen den einzelnen
kämpfen da muss man schauen dass man
runter kommt und sich einfach wieder neu
fokussiert und genau jedes mal wieder
neu hinein gehen einfach auch ähnliche
übungen macht sich wieder aktiviert
wieder fokussiert und dann aber sich
bereit noch für die nächsten kampf okay
danke schön
kniebeugen auf der matte ist eine option
sensomotorik zu trainieren
bis es für die unteren extremität mit
masse ja wir haben natürlich all die
rumpfmuskulatur da haben auch die
fliegende muskulatur gerade im bereich
rund um die wirbelsäule
das heißt da schauen wir uns jetzt
einmal den bereich rumpfmuskulatur
bislang mit einer bauch übung das heißt
sie tabs automatik jetzt einmal in
position und der erste tag ist einfach
ist setzt auf die matte gibt's hände und
füße weg vom boden und versucht einfach
immer das auszugleichen
das allein ist schon mal für den einen
oder anderen wahrscheinlich auch diese
herausforderung wurde es nichts zum
ausgleichen hergibt ja wenn das bomben
fix zum sitzen ist versucht sie mal die
beine kurz auszustrecken wieder
zurückzuziehen paar die sektion da muss
man schon ausgleichen da muss man schon
stabilisieren und das ist genau das was
bei dem training wichtig ist und den
drehen
es erfolg ausmacht die sichere eben auf
dem trainingsgerät desto weniger
trainingserfolg habe ich selbst einmal
die beine abstützen kann man mit den
händen ab auch da machen wir natürlich
wieder kurze pause
das heißt kurz die muskulatur entspannen
aus lockern
und dann macht man nur einen zweiten
durchgang im bereich der sit ups ihr
kennt natürlich auch probieren einmal
als variante die beine am boden lassen
und einmal mit dem oberkörper
zurückgehen und wieder hochkommen soweit
ist geht ohne wir mal dass man nach
hinten umfallen
ok also variante 2 nach hinten gehen was
möglich ist genau und dann wieder
vorziehen und nach hinten und wieder
vorziehen
und jetzt gehen wir noch einmal die
beine nach oben und probieren das ganze
mit beinen losgelöst von boden und jetzt
müssen wieder richtig ausgleichen
genau und wenn man mal nach hinten
umfeld passiert da nix weil so hoch vor
allem also das ist kein problem
gena okay dann die volkswagen stehen
wieder mehr auf die muskulatur kurz aus
wenn sie erinnert beim ersten mal habe
ich gesagt ein bein stand wichtiges
instrument wo man das trainieren kann
und die idee war es das in den alltag zu
integrieren und in den alltag einzubauen
ja und eine variante wäre die gewesen
dass man sagt okay
während ein zähneputzen steht mein bein
stand und versuchte das auszugleichen
wenn sie das gemacht habt jetzt heute
definitiv für einen fortschritt spüren
im einband stand wenn nicht dann eben
eine erinnerung da macht es ab jetzt
versucht einmal den einband stand auch
in euren alltag zu integrieren so wie
wir es jetzt mit euch auch machen das
heißt beginnen einmal herunten von der
matte ein band stand und dann mal
schauen wie sicher oder unsicher stehen
wir da überhaupt und wenn ihr das sicher
stehe dann gibt es natürlich varianten
wie das ganze verstärken kann
johannes wie kahn ist verstärken indem
ich schnell hin und her wechseln indem
ich zusperren auge einfach zu machen
genau das ist ein guter punkt wir machen
wir nur ein auge zu und nicht gleich
beide das heißt der punkt den man
fixieren zum ausgleichen der ist jetzt
schon mal verschoben da kann man dann
natürlich hin und her zwinkern quasi
alle 230 kunden dass man es wirklich
schwierig macht wechseln mal die seite
mal abgesehen vom augen schließen und
öffnen was canino verändern
umso komplexer zu machen das
mobilisieren was man am anfang für die
heiß wir säule gemacht haben das kann
man natürlich im einem bein stand
genauso machen und dann wird das
gleichgewichtsorgan schirme
durchgeschüttelt und entsprechend auch
belastet und das sieht man schon der fuß
muss ausgleichen die gelenke arbeiten ja
und das ist wie gesagt das training das
war's das dann interessant und wichtig
macht locker mal aus weil wir dürfen
natürlich die zeit nicht außer acht
lassen
das heißt weniger entsprechend zur
training macht dann immer wieder an die
pausen denken wie gesagt ganz wichtig
wir gestalten die pause in dem fall
meistens mit einer alternativen übung
das heißt wir lasten entlasten die beine
mal kurz und gehen aber wieder in die
rumpfmuskulatur hinein in dem fall in
die seitlichen bauchmuskulatur
das heißt und
amstutz auf der matte bernd auf der
matte bitte man darf sie bitten dass du
es der quer max das heißt einmal um 90
grad drehen geht es einmal in position
ihr wisst erkennst die übung bereits ihr
könnt es im langen hebel machen so wie
es der mangel vor zeigt oder auch am
kurzen hebe das heißt nie winkel
unterschenkel oberschenkel 90 grad und
das ganze ablegen dann ist es ein
bisserl einfacher aber ich muss da
ausgleichen
ja und da kann es mal ist natürlich
doppelt schwer machen im ausgleichen
indem ihr mit der oberen hand wiederum
bewegungen macht das heißt einmal nach
oben greifen arme durchgreifen und dann
muss ich ganz für ausgleichen und
arbeiten und da wollen wir wieder hin
manchmal nur fünf sekunden und wechselte
die seite gleich aus der opposition
heraus seite wechseln und noch einmal
die spannung aufbauen einmal hinein
spüren was passiert hatte
und wenn ich sicher steht bringe ich
eine variante hinein arm bewegen bein
bewegen sodass sie muskulär das ganze
ausgleichen muss
sie konnten 56 sekunden und wieder
aufstehen hier merkst wir haben den
belastungs wechsel gehabt wir wollen
zuerst auf den beinen zum stabilisieren
jetzt war die rumpfmuskulatur dran jetzt
wechselt man wieder zu den beinen und
ihnen ein weinstand das heißt wir haben
die einfache waren variante stehen
etwas komplizierter mit augenzwinkern
und kopf bewegen und jetzt probiere mal
das ganze einmal zu stabilisieren im
einband stand auf der matte das heißt
mit dem rechten bein am besten einmal
hinaufsteigen und sowie bei beiden
beinen spürt sommer hinein was muss da
ausgeglichen werden wie muss ich
arbeiten und das machen wir gerne und
der der sicher steht kann er natürlich
danach vor rollen auf der matte mit dem
bein biss zurückrollen so dass
mathematik bisschen bewegung setzen dass
man das ganze entsprechend ausgleichen
austarieren muss um das gleichgewicht
jedes mal neu finden muss seite wechseln
wieder nach vorn zurückrollen auf der
matte sucht euch einen punkt wo er
entsprechend gefordert sei aber noch
nicht überfordert
das ist ja ganz wichtiges thema beim
sensomotorik training
wenn man kurz ab gibt überhaupt kein
problem
sucht man ein gleichgewicht wieder
wieder runter von der matte aus lockern
und ausschütteln
das war natürlich da möglich ist da kann
man ganz viele machen und bewegungen
machen indem er sich am ball zu shift
indem man mit einem ball am boden bringt
indem man den ball gegen die mauer wird
und wieder fangen versucht das neusser
varianten die da bringen kann die wärme
danach gleich machen um entsprechend das
gleichgewicht doch noch mehr zu fordern
ja macht sie das beim festnahme habe sie
da sobald übungen mit dabei definitiv
das zeigen wir auch eine danach ok
supercool
das heißt wir werden das dann gleich
machen wir wechseln aber noch einmal
auch in die rückenmuskulatur hinein
das heißt ihr geht es bitte in den vier
füße rücklings das heißt spielen gang
beine oder arme auf der matte sucht sich
eine variante aus und da auch hebt es am
besten ein bein hoch und jetzt rollt mit
dem anderen bein nach vor und zurück und
dann muss ich schon wieder arbeiten da
wird schon wieder ausgeglichen da ist
schon wieder die muskulatur im ständigen
in der ständigen arbeit drinnen das
manchmal 30 sekunden in dem bereich
arbeiten ausgleichen
das becken ist oben der kopf auch hier
in verlängerung der wirbelsäule genau
dass man doch keine probleme danach habe
sie alle kriegen kurzen absätzen becken
kurz runter muskulatur aus locker lässt
zum krafttraining werden sondern wie
gesagt ein gleichgewicht beim training
bleiben
das heißt wir wechseln heißt die seite
findet die position genau und bewegt die
matte wieder nach form zurück und gleich
zum besten gut aus
hh
weißt du wie für aktive vechta gibt es
in österreich ein paar hundert würde ich
sagen okay also doch eine angebliche
zahlen doch eine zahl die man vielleicht
unterschätzt von relativ okay dann
stehen wir wieder auf wechseln wieder
belastungen stand am besten ist hier
stellt sich einmal gegenüber
die marke kenzo amour ruhig um 90°
vertreten dass man unterschiedliche
belastungen auf dem untergrund haben wir
schnappen unseren dennis bei und ihr
schaut euch einfach einmal ich leide
aber gesagt wir fahren einfach an einen
tennisball zu gibt es mit den anderen da
weil er genau für euch zu hause die
mauer kommt dabei genauso gut zurück und
wenn es zu zweit natürlich dann schon
recht zu und gesellschaft ist schon da
wird ausgeglichen am standbein der wird
ganz viel gearbeitet und da kann man sie
natürlich die arbeit schwerer machen
dass man nicht immer nur von der guten
von der starken wurf und von hand auf
die starke hand wirft sondern auch
einmal auf die schwache hand wirft dass
man entsprechend fangen und sie auf das
konzentrieren muss beim wechsel den
dürfen wir natürlich nicht außer acht
lassen und ihr kennt ja mal probieren
den ball ab bisserl aus der miete zu
werfen
das heißt nicht immer zentral vor den
körper genau sondern ein bisserl links
vorbei a bisserl rechts vorbei dann habe
ich schon wieder ganz große option mehr
und entsprechend auszugleichen kerner
und kannst du darunter von der matte die
30 sekunden die vergehen recht schnell
vor allem wenn man spielerisch mit einem
banner gestaltet wir gehen wieder in die
rumpfmuskulatur unterstützt auf der
matte unterarme drauf und auch hier die
übung gibt's gratis ohne mathe ja genau
so versucht einmal die schultern nach
vor zu bewegen das heißt eine säge
bewegung nach vor und zurück aber jetzt
nicht nur aus dem sprunggelenk sondern
versucht die marke zubewegen das heißt
genau bewegt seine unterarme zweimal
mobile unterlage damit dabei die last
sich bewegen und jetzt wird es schon
richtig intensiv wie die bauchmuskulatur
also für die vordere muskel kette
deswegen gesagt wir beachten wie die
zeit dass wir das nicht überlasten
sehen sie konnten
drei zwei eins und wieder aufstehen wir
probieren sie jetzt gleich mit zwei
bällen
das heißt angeregt emanuel einem
glückstor johannes wieder im heim
entstand und versucht sich einmal auf
kleines kommando dass man nicht
unterschiedlich werfen das zuzuwerfen
wichtig war in dem fall dass die zwei
sich absprechen dass das gut
funktionieren kann
und jetzt ist es eine mobile komponente
mehr drinnen
und es wird immer schwieriger obwohl man
nach wie vor nur unter
anführungsstrichen dem ein bein stand
stehen das ganze auszugleichen und
entsprechend gut und sicher zu stehen
seite wechseln
[Musik]
18 sie konnte
das nehmen wir als anlass heraus kann
gut ausgeglichen genau kämpfen um die
position
und wenn das gleichgewicht dann
nachlässt dann einfach wieder ausloggen
ausschütten und dann kriegen wir das
schon wieder hin
ok so wie vorher wir wechseln wieder in
die rumpfmuskulatur mitnehmen wieder den
bauch das heißt vierfüßlerstand hände
auf die matte
das ist einmal noch nicht so tragisch
jetzt versucht zumal die knie so 2 cm
vom boden weg zu bewegen und einmal die
hand noch eine hand im wechsel nach
vorne nach hinten also einfach
ausstrecken und wieder auf die matte
dazu geben genau und die andere seite
muss entsprechend ausgleichen
das ist für viele ohne magische
herausforderung in dem fall ist es mit
tomate natürlich doppelt schwierig das
ganze auszugleichen und nehmen gleich
mal die hände auf die matte und machen
wir mit den beinen dabei ein wechsel
hochheben linkes bein rechtes bein und
matisse muskuläres zieht dann wird
verursacht und das ist erst wie man ganz
schön in die tiefliegenden muskulatur da
reinkommen kurze base knie unter kurz
aus lockern an zweiten durchgang
bauchmuskulatur macht man auch und jetzt
kombinieren bein heben und hand heben
diagonal das als plinke handwerk rechtes
bein weg und im wechsel nach links und
nach rechts
wenn es bereits los
und genau aus gleichen austarieren
bei einer hin- und herwechseln sekunden
auf
und stehen wieder auf und macht mal
wieder den wechsel aber gegner entstand
ok einmal stand auf der matte und eine
der schwierigsten varianten ist es
natürlich das ganze mit geschlossenen
augen zu machen das heißt wo wir jetzt
einmal stellt sich auf die matte im
einbein stand konzentriert und schließt
die augen und bevor man runterfällt
augen öffnen absteigen und von vorne
wieder probieren seite wechseln
ausgleichen konzentrieren
ok runtersteigen öffnen auslagern
wie war das von der schwierigkeit der
war das jetzt einfach friedlich oder war
das jetzt genau das war auch für mich
recht schwer okay aber das soll auch so
sein genau das sein das ausgleichen die
sind doch ganz wichtig und dafür euch zu
hause wenn ihr das beim ersten mal nicht
so gut umsetzen kann es überhaupt kein
problem macht sehr leichtere variante
dann funktioniert das eigentlich immer
sehr sehr gut ok dann gern mal ins
becken hin manchmal keine rücken übung
wieder das heißt becken liegt füße am
boden also füße automatik oberkörper am
boden so machen was man will darf
gebieten 90° vertreten dass man das von
der seite auch sehen
legt euch nieder genau becken hoch und
wieder runter und das ganze ist
natürlich wenn man mit beiden beinen am
boden ist jetzt nicht einfach das netz
an aber zum ausgleichen relativ wenig da
aber wenn ich ein beim hochheben
danwerth merken da ist schon wieder zu
arbeiten da ist schon wieder zum
ausgleichen und back nicht heben und
senken dazu habe eine dynamische
bewegung mit dabei und dann wird wieder
richtig zum ausgleichen
der noch kurz zum ausrasten die
muskulatur seite wechseln und dann geht
schon wieder los zweite seite
drei wiederholungen machen wir nur eins
zwei und drei stehen wir wieder auf
jeder hat seine marke vor sich beine
locker aus jetzt da für euch zuhause
wechselt einmal die orientierung der
matte
das heißt jetzt nicht immer der quer auf
thematisch schon einmal kann ruhig
einmal der längst drauf steigen das
verhalten der matte wird wieder ganz
anders in der sekunde was macht okay das
heißt die kinder abwechselnd ich glaube
er war ze immer auf der breitseite
jetzt nehmen wir mal die längsseite her
wieder immer ein bein stand und jetzt
schauen wir dass man eine dynamik
hineinbringen
nur wir für uns aber das gibt's einmal
nach vorne so weit wie es geht nach vor
mit dem bein kommt wieder hoch gleicht
aus gibt's auf die seite kommt wieder
vor und gleicht wieder aus
das ganze natürlich zurück nur kurz ab
dippel und auf die andere seite vorne
vorbei hinten vorbei beide varianten ok
kurz ausgleichen stabilisieren
heruntersteigen aus locker
das reicht wenn man das schon langsam
macht seien 20 bis 30 sekunden gleich
vorbei wenn wir die zweite seite zweites
bein und wieder nach vor kurz abtippen
nach zur seite andere seite genau und
nach hinten ausgleichen stabilisieren
und wieder runterkommen von der matte
das machen wir kein zweites mal wenn man
wirklich schöne dynamik drinnen haben
jetzt aber im kreis das heißt dass man
nicht immer die gleiche die gleiche
richtung haben wechselt nochmal die
richtung okay
zwei seitenarme oder bzw in dem fall die
erste seite das andere bein noch einmal
und beginn zurück seite genau zweite
seite und nach vor
kurz ausgleichen stabilisieren und
absteigen und gleich wieder wechsel
zweite seite und zurück seite seite und
nach vor und wieder ausgleichen
stabilisieren und wieder runter genau
hier setzt sensomotorik training kann so
einfach sein aber so effektiv und so
effizient in einer sturzprophylaxe im
aufpassen dass nichts passiert im
stabilisieren von gelenken wo ich glaube
dass der leistungssport ist der das
braucht oder auch das alltägliche dasein
ausrutschen auf ein eis gehen davon auf
dem waldboden wurzel ist rutschig
man rutscht auf die seite gestürzt nicht
gleich mal bricht sie nichts mehr tue
nicht weh wenn man das regelmäßig ein
bad ist es super super sache für euch zu
hause ja das gibt's was hast du den
leuten noch im speziellen mitgeben
möchte ist im lock down zum training
also unbedingt trainieren auch unbedingt
das machen weil wie du richtig sagst
prävention gegen verletzungen das ist
das nonplusultra in dem moment genau das
heißt auch die trainingseinheiten die
net 100% jetzt nämlich körperlich
auslasten seien wichtig es ist die
regeneration wichtig dass danach lässt
man oft es ist die sensomotorik training
die tiefenmuskulatur wichtig
vernachlässigen oft ist genauso ein
wichtiger punkt im aufbau wichtiger
punkt eben um gesund und fit zu bleiben
leute für heute was das sensomotorik
training und gleichgewichtstraining
haben abgeschlossen ich sage danke
manuel dank johannes dass ihr
mittrainiert hat wir freuen uns auf
morgen morgen ist stabil training also
der statt training am programm wir haben
wieder eine fechterin bei uns die olivia
wohlgemuth als zugführer und hier als
leistungssportler
wir freuen uns auf euch stolz machen
wieder ein wir sind da für euch